[Music]
welcome to session 61 in the world of
speculative fiction
series this time we are going to be
looking at these books specifically and
mostly
these two in a duology rather than a
trilogy
but also in two short stories that are
contained in this book as well so these
are all by veronica
roth they're all very recent works we
have the
carve the mark and the fates divide from
the carve the mark universe or duology
and then in her book of short stories
the end and other beginnings stories
from the future which beautifully
illustrated by the way
we have um
two stories
that are
coming from that that same
universe telling the stories of some of
the characters some of the backstory
stuff so um
i also have some stories about this that
i'll tell you in just a moment but
i've been waiting to do these for
quite a while
i got this book
actually
by being present for a
meet the
readers
event at boswell bookstore that veronica
roth was at and i was actually sitting
next to her in part because
her agent reached out to me and said
would you mind accompanying her and
answering some of the the questions and
engaging in some conversation i was very
delighted because my kids had read
divergent and insurgent in that whole
series
and uh i thought that was it was quite
cool a really interesting way to do
things so i got my my book of course
actually i got i had two copies one for
me and one for my kids and
she signed both of them and it was it
was very nice we got to meet the the
owner and veronica roth herself her
husband her agent and we had a great
conversation
and i
emailed her afterwards and we had an
exchange where i asked her
um
here's the question there's the
narrative universe of the divergent
series and then there's that of carve
the mark works which do you think might
make for a better discussion for the
worlds of speculative fiction series and
she actually wrote a
thoughtful response i'm going to read it
to you right here
as for my books i'm flattered that you
want to include some it's hard for me to
answer of course divergent is perhaps
the most obvious and direct choice as
the whole splitting society into virtue
based factions things is right there to
chat about
however
i am partial to the world of carve the
mark i think it's better constructed for
one thing as i was older and more
experienced when i wrote it but it also
asks some interesting questions about
fate versus free will religion versus
secular government violence versus mercy
whether violence and cruelty are
inherited and so forth the whole first
book also deals with the outside
perception of this warrior culture as
opposed to the insider view of it
outsiders view the shotet as violent
backwards scavengers but the shotet
themselves have a rich culture and
legitimate claim to their planet and
their sovereignty i don't know i think
there's a lot there though i found it
incredibly difficult to pitch to readers
it's more like fantasy that way it's
hard to summarize a fantasy world but a
dystopia is just our world turned
sideways so
i think this is is quite an interesting
set of reflections on it and i very much
enjoyed
uh reading these i think they're
actually quite well
put together you know the story gives
you just enough it's sort of tantalizing
she's doing a lot of world building
that is being revealed but there's so
much more that could be revealed it's
kind of uh
you know a little bit more uh developed
but but kind of like ursula k le guin in
that respect right there's still lots of
corners of earth see that we could
explore
if ursula k leguin were still around
writing novels now fortunately veronica
roth herself is and who knows maybe
she'll add to this later on we have
scheduled sessions
on uh this universe
several different times the year that we
were going to do that we got stopped by
kovid
and the worlds of speculative fiction
went from what it originally was a
monthly
gathering at the brookfield public
library where we would look at like a
you know an author and series of works
that have a consistent narrative world
and then discuss it and i would video
record it it went from that to later on
that year in 2020 the format that we're
now using
which is a roughly
90 minute sometimes i go a little over
long video that i premiere and we do you
know live chat on that and then
afterwards we follow up the session with
a bit more interaction using
zoom to get together and chat about you
know all the other things that we didn't
get to in talking about those and
sometimes our conversations veer off in
other directions as is common with these
sort of book focused
interactions now the world's a
speculative fiction series if you're not
familiar with it you know what we do
here is i give a bit of biography if we
haven't already covered that author
with roth there isn't a ton of biography
because she's still pretty young
then we look at some some you know
narrative world building and some of the
key philosophical themes you notice in
that email response to me that i was
reading off
roth brought up you know fate versus
free will well that's a philosophical
theme that we're definitely going to
explore
and i also like to bring in you know
some interviews or reviews where
the author is themself talking about
their own process and their own work
because i think we get a good idea about
what they're doing there and so i've got
some of that stored away for it for you
so um
a lot of cool stuff
in these stories a lot of interesting
characters a lot of great world building
and some
great philosophical themes that we're
going to
shortly delve into
this biography section can be relatively
short which is great because then that
saves us more time for discussing the
world building and philosophical themes
and that's the case because veronica
roth is a fairly young author in her
early 30s born in 1988 she already has a
string of
novels behind her and seems to have
quite a bit of momentum going which is a
a great thing to see
so let's launch into it and then you
know after that we'll get into some some
reviews and then world building and then
philosophical themes now her website
biography is very very short i'm just
going to read it to you by contrast to
what we're doing here veronica roth is
the new york times best-selling author
of chosen ones the short story
collection
the end and other beginnings the
divergent series and the
carve the mark
duology she is also the guest editor of
the most
recent the best american science fiction
and fantasy and she lives in chicago
illinois very nice short succinct blurb
there
and you know she does in fact live in in
chicago or chicagoland we could say she
was born in 1988 in new york city uh
about her mother is barbara ross her
maternal grandparents were actually
concentration camp survivors and
their religious convictions apparently
pushed their mother away from religion
veronica herself is going to have a
coming to it through going to uh you
know sort of a bible
camp uh
thing in high school later on the
christian bible study
her father as she says worked away and
by the time that veronica was five her
mother and father were divorced and
apparently he didn't have much
you know connection to the rest of her
life her mother remarried and
you know veronica then had a stepfather
she went to you know a
normal set of of schools grove avenue
elementary school prairie middle school
barrington high school barrington is
kind of a northern suburb
in the chicagoland area and you know
that's where she went to a christian
bible study where she started to you
know explore religious ideas and themes
and stuff like that
and
you know she followed sort of a normal
trajectory for i guess you could say
you know a lot of kids in in the uh
these sorts of cities right she goes off
to college although she uh transfers so
she goes to carlton college and spends a
year there and then she transfers to
northwestern university and if you don't
know northwestern it's you know it's
sort of like one of the big
um
if we had ivy league schools besides
university of chicago
here in the midwest it would be it would
be you know in that running right
northwestern is known for a lot of
different fields and contributions
and she enrolls in the creative writing
program and this is you know kind of an
interesting
feature
of her biography that we'll get into in
a little bit in the interviews stuff so
she's you know in a program doing
creative writing and you know if you
don't know much about these
they
range incredibly
in approach and quality and engagement
you know i for example was i didn't i
didn't major in writing at all but i
hung around with the writing people when
i was in college
and you know depending on who you were
working with you might get some guidance
or you might just get criticism
and it was very there wasn't a lot of
emphasis on learning how to publish or
anything back then but better programs
really give you a lot of good
criticism of the positive kind the kind
that you can use to
improve your works and craft and writing
is understood not as something that you
have an innate talent for in this
romantic sense it's understood as a
craft something that you really got to
work your butt off at again i mentioned
ursula kayla green just a little bit
earlier ursula k le guin would tell you
the same in many of her essays and so
veronica roth you could think of as kind
of
a
product and a
deliberate
user
of the resources when it comes to
writing that have been developed in the
last couple centuries and available
in a good program so
she uh she writes divergent well she
writes a bunch of other you know
things before that but
not you know uh
not quite of such an important scope but
she writes divergent over winter break
her senior
year and you can well imagine that it's
not just her having a flash of
inspiration and then you know writing uh
non-stop at the keyboard there's a lot
of world building and thinking things
out that goes into it before that but
interestingly things really fell into
place
she finds an agent before she actually
graduates
and her film rights are sold by
mid-march 2011
before the novel was actually printed in
april
2011. now she's this is shortly after
she's graduating
filming for divergent started in april
2013 and then the film was released in
march 2014
now if you look at that and you also
look at the publication
schedule you could call it of her other
novels in that series in part insurgent
comes out in 2012
allegiant comes out in 2013.
the world of divergent the path to
allegiance 2013 as well and then for
a divergent collection 2014. so it's one
one after another this is very
productive when it comes to the
narrative world that's being developed
and
um by the time that the movie is coming
out you notice she's already got
two
or three well actually
several books out available for people
who are getting into it through
the movie which is you know pretty
pretty smart
um then you know what we see coming
later is in 2017 we can be mended
and then
carve the mark in 2017 and this is you
know you notice quite a substantive
volume um it is i mean not including the
glossary and acknowledgments 468 pages
so this is a solid tome and then she
brings out the fates divide the
follow-up uh
set to it
which again uh so
skipping the acknowledgements 443 pages
so you know this is
uh you know over 900 pages of work and
if we add in those two short stories you
could say a thousand pages of
development
and then arc
the ebook part of amazon's forward
kindle collection comes out in 2019 the
end and other beginnings comes out also
in 2019 that is where she
went on the uh
book tour and uh that's where i met uh
veronica roth her husband nelson fitch
who she married in 2011 a photographer
and her agent as well and
she's also had some new things coming
out as well
chosen ones in 2020
poster girl in 2022 there's another book
that i believe is slated for
2023 so roth has remained quite
productive i mean this is a pretty
significant body of work spanning
several narrative universes already
going into her early 30s and i'll just
say that i you know
you know i imagine there's going to be a
lot of great productive years ahead
i probably would enjoy
uh seeing more books in the car of the
mark
series coming out it's uh finished in in
certain arcs but it maybe it's not
completely
finished so who knows what the decades
to come
will bring in terms of additional
development of this narrative universe
just to wet your whistle a little bit as
they say about the world building
aspects we're going to do a bit of that
and then we'll look at some of the
interviews
that roth has given and then we'll come
back to talking about world building in
a more substantive way there is a
you could say a sliver of the world
building or maybe a central aspect of it
that i think we can
treat fairly easily and give you
something that you can sink your teeth
into
a little bit so it's happening in the
galaxy but the galaxy as it turns out is
a little bit misnamed because it's
really a
solar system and there's a very uh
elegant
map of it that is provided at the very
beginning of carve the mark and i'll put
let me put that into the
video itself for you so you can take a
look at it we'll scroll through it a
little bit so you can get a sense of
what we've got here and you know it's
it's laid out quite nicely although in a
sense that that doesn't completely
depict it graphically you know in a
accurate sense because we've got this
assembly ship that's above everything
else and we'll talk about that in a
moment so we have a solar system right
we have a sun
with a number of planets
and then it's surrounded by this current
stream barrier and then a whole bunch of
other smaller planetoids or planets
called the brim
and each of the planets within the inner
solar system has a name and you could
say has a determinate culture a way of
life and then with the brim it's you
know sort of
like our asteroid belt you know if
people were living on some of the big
asteroids or moons in the outer planets
it would be like that
there are two ships that play
a
significant role in this one of them is
on
the planet of
thuva most of the time
but it does travel to other places and
we'll we'll talk about that in a bit and
then there's the assembly ship and the
assembly is
you could think of it as a
supraplanet
organization a government that is
allowing sovereignty of planets and also
of peoples to a certain degree
but also providing a structure an order
in which things can be addressed and and
resolved and so we've got all these
interesting planets as
locations as settings
for
the action the plots the character
development that's going to take place
so the first one of course is uh thuva
which is where a lot of the action is
taking place
and carve the mark
and
you know good portion of it in fate's
divide
and also much of the
action in in the two stories here in the
end and other beginnings and this is the
planet where our story originates
with the the attack
on a family
by
members of a different ethnicity a
different nation that is living there
there's two nations living together on
thuva there's the shotet and the
sit and these have been clashing for
generations and generations they there's
a divide in between them of feather
grass which is a uh you know big thick
type of foliage that will also like give
you hallucinations and things like that
and it's a fairly cold planet as a
matter of fact that's why certain
important flowers grow there
[Music]
and so there are these these two
different sides
and the assembly recognizes the planet
as thuva it doesn't yet although they're
pushing for it recognize
shotet sovereignty whether as rulers of
the planet or as a secondary group on
the planet so that's that's one
important place and you know there's a
lot of discussion of the kinds of cold
going on there and the different
um
animals you know for example the armored
ones that we're going to talk about
in a bit as as playing a very
interesting role particularly in
relation to the current
another one of the planets that's
discussed very early on is uh ulthir
um
some it's it's known for its medical
innovations
and this is where uh kira is going to go
for
some attempted treatments or at least
diagnoses of what's going
on with her and
you know what else do we know about it
the people of ulther have a fondness for
small useless objects it's it you know
it's got its own kind of culture
and shtick to it
another that kira visits zold
and the planet surface is covered with
grey dust during part of the year that
comes from local flowers you have to
wear goggles
you remove
this when there's off-world guests
there's supposed to be a shoted exile
colony on zold
and we're going to talk about that in
just a bit you know the exiles and and
who they are why would they be exiled
pitha is another
planet a water planet it's covered with
water they develop all sorts of tools
and and weapons
they use synthetic materials imported
from other places their their buildings
are these these glass structures the
cities actually ride the currents
of the uh
of the the vast ocean you could call it
and uh they they make all sorts of other
things as well they their technology
providers you could say including of of
garments clothing and stuff like that
then we have a very interesting planet
that gets
just a little bit of reference and carve
the mark but then winds up being a major
location
for the fates divide and that is ogra
ogra is
called
there's a definition for it the living
dark
it's
inaccessible to most of the other
planets it's mysterious and they like it
that way
they have their own culture that's you
know sort of devoted to
life on that world they don't allow a
lot of visitors technology you know
scanning and stuff like that can't
penetrate the atmosphere
and um you know they the
landing there is incredibly difficult
you actually
need to
go into free fall it takes great pilot
skill there's a very interesting passage
where
the very first time
when you land they say congratulations
on your safe arrival which is not
something that you typically say right
when people are landing but every single
arrival on ogra is like that
and ogre itself is a dark inhospitable
world where even the plants are trying
to kill you right so it's a constant
struggle for
um
survival and thriving on the part of the
human beings who are there
and interestingly the current gifts that
people have the further you get closer
to the surface the stronger they become
which can be a good thing
or can be a bad thing depending on what
kind of gift you actually have in the
case of kira you know
her susceptibility to pain and you know
ability to transfer pain to others is
incredibly amped up as well which is not
a gift for her but rather a suffering
and so you know ogra ogre is also
important for one other thing so i
mentioned this you know this rumor that
the shotet exiles are on uh zold but it
actually turns out that
they're they're on ogra which is the
place where they can uh stay and hide
then we have
several other planets that play
less of an important role uh trella
which is noted for being a a bird planet
having skies full of birds with high
mountains and stuff like that tepes uh
the planet closest to the sun so a lot
hotter they make synthetic fabrics
the planet's so hot that you can't walk
on it barefoot asunder
mines a current blocking metal that
ogren's use on their boats to protect
against the predators because predators
can sense the current in people and and
go after it
then we have uh kolanda uh people don't
know much about this and we don't get a
lot of discussion it also
has some some medical things and we
should mention that thuva has these
flowers that are used for medical uses
as well the assembly leader is from
kolanda
and
you know some of these worlds you could
say are a bit more religious and others
are more secular or you could say
they're they're more you know into
empiricism technology you know sort of a
way of life that's leaving
the religion behind and i i've mentioned
the current
so the current is a
pervasive feature of this narrative
universe the current flows through
all sorts of things and is in all sorts
of things animals can sense it so like
the armored ones for example try to
there these massive
land creatures try to attack people
because they don't like the sound or the
smell or the the sensation of the
current in human beings and every human
being has some sort of
thing that's called a gift oftentimes
it's not really a gift
because it imposes restrictions on you
or problems on you that is associated
with the current we'll talk about that a
little bit more
later
but it's there and it's considered
important and so that that's you know
kind of part of the backdrop so here we
have the solar system as such i should
mention of course the brim people coming
from the brim are treated as if they're
you know not as good as people coming
from the inner planets there's a bit of
a superiority inferior inferiority thing
there as well
but you know all of this is uh
the universe
the pretty vast universe in which all of
the action
of these stories is going to take place
veronica roth has done a vast number of
interviews in recent years that gives us
insights into her writing process and
the world building going on and even
into her own
character as well as that of her
characters and her approach to things
and so
i thought it would be useful for us to
look at a few of these i i did in fact
reach out but i didn't unfortunately get
any uh response in asking you know if i
could shoot some interview questions but
one of the interviews
namely the npr interview kind of touches
on
this um she was talking about her own
struggle with anxiety saying it's
particularly provoked by social
interaction and i have to do a lot of
that these days i can't just hole up
which is what i would like to do so it
became particularly urgent when the
divergent series became popular to you
know seek some help and i've done a lot
of work to make my job doable for me but
it continues to be difficult so what we
have here is somebody who is you know
rather um
you know more on the introvert side and
uh probably gets like constant
engagement rough people and it's it's
kind of you could say wow what a what a
great problem to have yes but also
no for for many people and i think that
some of that gets folded into
some of the characters in these books as
well i think that roth uses her own and
many other people's experience as raw
material to to develop these characters
i'd actually like to begin with the
entertainment weekly
interview which i think is particularly
germane to
um
these these works actually i'm going to
begin with a different short little
blurb from the ivy magazine interview
she says with carve the mark it's a big
universe and has lots of points of
inspiration so it's a little different
from divergent it wasn't just one idea
it was a hundred ideas mashed together
in one i followed my curiosity which is
my motto these days
i think this is roth setting is super
important it could become a huge part of
what what makes the story work setting
and story have to work together
yet i sometimes feel
people really fall in love with their
world and they forget we need to be
propelled through that world this is a
very important remark about world
buildings let's just pause on a mass so
as i mentioned a little bit earlier
lots of world building going on in these
and yet at the same time it is like that
you know propelling through the world
we're getting views
of things through flashbacks and
interactions and sayings and memories
the exposition is happening
typically through those means and we're
getting enough to make sense out of
where we are at a given time there's no
like pause for an entire chapter on i
know the history of the showtime or
something like that it's uh it's very
important as ross said to have a
dialectic between
uh story and and setting
so she says um not everybody will see it
in the way that you do so what we need
is a character with an interesting
struggle that will carry us through it i
think the setting and story need to be
held in tension with each other for me i
guess the story is a little bit higher
on the priority list but i also write
super commercial fiction so it depends
on what kind of story you're
writing so you know
we have two really main characters in
carve the mark right and the story is
essentially told the chapters you know
are like chapter 16 kira right we get a
view through her view and then we have
akkos
um and i i don't think that we have
anybody
else's point of view
in those we do get their their point of
view through what they say to kira and
akkos but then we have others where um
aja is is uh aj is kind of a dual person
by that time and um
the brother of akkos
and
then we have [ __ ] as well
and uh so there's there's a
lot of
characters driving
this this story as she's saying so in
entertainment weekly now we'll come to
that they asked her how did you approach
this second book working off carve the
mark
so roth says the more books i write the
more of a planner i become i didn't used
to be
but i think the longer you go on the
more you realize you can make it easier
for yourself by coming up with a plan
beforehand
i definitely had an outline but it's
important to balance having a sense of
direction with leaving room for
spontaneity you don't always know it's
going to work once it's on the page
that's how i tried to approach it if it
wasn't working i had to be willing to
change it which is difficult for authors
right
and then she's asked what kind of themes
are you exploring in this follow-up she
said i wanted to send everybody to new
worlds right so to ogun right
there there's all these planets in the
solar system and in the first book we
really only see one one of the most
exciting parts of it was writing about
ogre which was introduced in the first
book of the shadow planet it's
mysterious no one's met ograns they
don't know how they live or what their
world looks like
substantial portion of the faith divide
takes place on the planet so we get to
see
how that shadow planet lives that was
really exciting and then she goes on but
on a bigger note one of the biggest
ideas i tried to tackle is what young
women do
with power
very interesting
theme right the book is
so centered on not just kira but on
akos's sister [ __ ] and they're all
these very different young women there's
also you know the the um
leader of the uh thu visit herself who
has to engage in in war against the
shotet um
so then the the follow-up question
how do you approach balancing that
with the world building in this
complicated sci-fi world you've created
and so roth says
i try to make sure they're tied together
these women come from specific places so
the important thing is to show how these
places
affect who they've become that way you
can tie character and world building
together
everybody is a product of their culture
in some way how they buy into that
culture's priorities how they deviate
from it is an important part of
character and world building i would say
that's a very important philosophical
theme as well
to what extent
are people
even in you know not just what they
accept or what they promote but even
what they reject and fight against how
are they determined by their environment
and culture this goes all the way back
to reflection on this in the western
tradition
in you know plato and aristotle and
cicero and people like that with what we
can call geographic determinism right
and it's carried through
into
the present
going on a little bit a little bit
further into a different interview the
guardian interview
somebody else was there anything which
pulled you towards writing a sci-fi book
and she she answers i consider dystopian
fiction to be under the sci-fi umbrella
so as far as i'm concerned i've always
been writing sci-fi but basically i just
wanted to get really really creative so
just talking about these books now right
i wanted to let go of our world
completely and throw all my assumptions
out the window for example
does this new world have to be
patriarchal do they have marriage how is
their technology developed differently
from ours
by the time i was finished answering all
these questions i had a sci-fi fantasy
universe it wasn't really surprising
whether it was reading dune by frank
herbert when i was younger or binge
watching firefly i've always liked that
kind of setting fantastical but
futuristic
and then she's asked we're going to come
back to this this theme about you know
genres in a bit what made you decide to
write a duology rather than a trilogy or
a standalone book this is a great
question because we don't see a lot of
duologies out there we see stand-alone
books
or we see
trilogies is a very you know common one
or trilogies that spiral off into
whole sets of things you know for
example george r martin's game of
thrones song of ice and fire originally
i believe was supposed to be a trilogy
and then it got bigger and bigger and
bigger and
you know divergent itself there's four
to that
um
you know there's there's all sorts of
other works
are scott backer's work as a totality
was supposed to be a trilogy the first
book of which turned into a trilogy the
second book of which turned into a
quadrilogy and we could go on and on and
on and on there's not a lot of duologies
out there you know one great example of
that would be
octavia butler's parable series right
you say well what about those two the
parable of the sower the parable of the
talents
she actually intended to write six but
unfortunately wasn't able to do so
so to deliberately
make a duology
supplemented of course by the two short
stories in here
that's kind of a deliberate choice so
what does roth say
i set out to write a standalone book but
as i wrote i realized it just wasn't
enough time with the characters for me
the stories kept growing and i wanted to
let them grow i did outline it as both a
duology and a trilogy to see which one
worked better
a trilogy has to have three distinct
arcs though and carve the mark
only had two so the choice was pretty
easy
isn't that interesting you know so
deliberate structure
there
what else
so let's look at this other interview
coming from the tennessean
which was quite good
they said i know you did a lot of
deliberate world building for carve the
mark i'd love to hear specifically about
the process of creating the showtent
which are you know in some respect you
could call them the main drivers of the
entire
narrative in one way or another so she
says
my idea for the shotet was for the
reader to experience them primarily the
way that acos does
at first
he sees them almost as monsters but they
aren't and the longer he spends with
them the more impossible that fact
becomes to ignore
in order to develop all of the distinct
cultures in the book i determined their
highest priorities and for the shotet
that priority is survival
they have been oppressed by the powerful
galactic government in the past they
continue to be now so they've become
strong yes sometimes violent to fight
for their own rights and sovereignty
they're also resourceful in order to
survive and know how to repurpose things
other people would discard they have a
strong sense of belonging to each other
rather than to a place because they know
how easy it is to take a place away
from someone basically what i'm saying
is
just by knowing what someone's highest
priority is
you can figure out a lot about them and
this is a very important philosophical
theme as well again that one that we see
running throughout
ancient western philosophy and and other
philosophies as well running throughout
all the way to the present when you know
what somebody's order of values are what
they really are not just what they
profess but what they
show themselves to be committed to you
really know a lot about them
she also talks about their language
their language is an important part of
their creation since their language is a
huge emotional part of their culture
here she says something quite
interesting i decided to draw on my
experience with hungarian from when i
lived in collusion apoca romania where
there's a large hungarian population to
someone who's never heard it before
hungarian sounds a bit harsh a little
odd but i was in church there on
christmas when we sang hungarian
christmas songs and they were so
haunting so beautiful that experience
was powerful for me i wanted shotet to
sound harsh too to people who don't
speak it
but just because outsiders don't
understand something doesn't mean that
it's not beautiful
and there's a nice follow-up question to
this a little bit later in the journey
of writing the book which emerged first
kira's personality or the shotet as
people and
roth answers the shot kira wasn't even
in
some of my initial part drafts but i
needed a way to keep our antagonist
ryzek in the picture a little more so i
put her in the story to connect me and
then it was like she just elbowed her
way in more and more until she'd had
just as many words as
aakos so you know a lot of the world
building here as she's saying is
you could call it ethnological what is
this people who travel throughout the
solar system don't really have an
established home
anywhere got pushed around a lot abused
had to become very strong by response
even tyrannical now and you know liable
to
being misled by their their rulers
um
here's another uh aspect that i wanted
to
to talk about um
this is from the hypeable interview
i was wondering if there were
other reasons uh behind this choice or
is there something that appeals to you
in using third person versus first
person and i should mention here
that in the chapters
in in these the the work is in you could
say first person point of view but also
third person right behind the shoulders
point of view and what do we mean by
that so first person point of view
you're all familiar with that i you know
we etc so you know
at the very beginning right
um
it you know she it's the very very first
chapter we had held a funeral for my
father on the first sojourn after his
passing sent his old armor into space my
brother
said my mother had called you know so
we're getting a very much first person
point of view
in a lot of the other chapters for for
instance those for akkos we're getting
you know
the thoughts in accos his head we're
getting what he says we're getting his
reactions his actions but told in a
third person point of view as if we're
following along with him here's where it
gets really interesting
in these works
there are several first-person point of
views
several third-person point of views
they're not distinguished on the basis
of who belongs to which ethnicity
they're distinguished on the basis of
gender
so kira and [ __ ] are told in first
person point of view both women right
young women
and
um akkos and his brother
sort of brother well also brother in
ways that we're going to talk about in a
bit
aja
is told in third person point of view
so
what's going on with that
so she's asked about that
she says
i love your observation about first
person and third person because i can
certainly think that was a big part of
it i wrote one character in the third
person in the car of the mark series
akkos and it was for the same reasons
you listed which is now was it a matter
of gender
she says this
he's a more guarded and weary character
and when you read in third person even
if it's close
third person you feel a little bit more
separate from that character
but otherwise to be honest divergent and
even the first person parts of carve the
mark were the exception for me i'd
always written in third person up to
that point
and it it felt right and divergent for
you to be in her head and then for carve
the mark to be in kira's head but i
think third person is kind of my default
i always start every project in that
voice and if it works i keep it if it
doesn't i change it
but i find it to be more challenging at
the outset because you're not literally
in the character's head which makes you
feel like you know them a little better
from the beginning third person is
harder at first and then it's easier
over the time
whereas the first person is the
opposite
then there was a follow-up
while carve the mark was told from two
different perspectives as well as two
different narrative voices you diversify
the storytelling and the fates divide
even more
i found the addition of aegia's voice to
be the most interesting why did you
choose to tell parts of the fate's
divide from his perspective and roth
responds agent resolved one of the big
problems i had in the fates divide which
is how do you show things that are
happening on the other side of the
galaxy without having a bunch of
characters standing around futuristic
space tvs through his perspective these
big events become personal which was a
huge help but he also offered the
opportunity to get into some of the
weirdness of current gifts how much they
are as much curses as gifts how they
change and shift and warp as a person
goes through life and so this is
actually a great segue into
one of the things from the npr interview
which has to do with a particular
current gift
why did she want to explore chronic pain
in these novels and
roth says i had several friends who
experienced chronic pain over you know
like a decade and had their pain
underestimated by doctors which
statistically is more likely if you're a
woman by a drastic degree and they were
eventually diagnosed with endometriosis
this is like a couple people in my just
in my immediate social circle so i
thought about them a lot
about how pain takes over your life and
limits your potential
and how difficult it can be to find
someone who will take it
seriously
that's kind of kyra's struggle her pain
is being underestimated by the people
around her and she still finds a way to
act in spite of it which is a creditor
strength
kira didn't start out as a really
important character in the story but she
felt urgent to me and i think that's
partly because of those women who have
been such powerful examples
in my life which i think is a very
interesting
thing to say isn't it
well we'll finish up here with
one last thing from hypeable
so she was asked the ending satisfies
our need to know about what happened to
all the characters but it leaves the
overarching planetary unrest relatively
unresolved
is this world one you're hoping to
return to in the future or did you have
other reasons to leave larger scale
loose ends
untied
so here's what ross said and this goes
to the you know will she write some more
stuff
my reason for leaving some large-scale
loose ends untied is basically to give
the appropriate respect to these kinds
of conflicts war
divides nations it devastates people and
the ripple effects last for a long long
time a peace treaty or an armistice
doesn't make everything okay again
sometimes it just establishes a short
break before fighting breaks out again
so with the conflict i'd set up i knew i
couldn't resolve it at the end that it
might never resolve with finality that
said
i'd love to return to this universe
someday there's so much to explore there
but for now
i'm satisfied with how these character
stories
wrapped up and
you know what do we see uh not long
after that well these characters
stories
um getting reassessed in in uh here we
go armored ones two stories of shotet
metal so two stories
one
of teka right
told in the first person right taka is
an important uh shotet exile character
and operative
in um
all of this and she's being
trained to kill kira and then we have
akkos and then akkos interestingly again
still told
in the third
person
so she did revisit the world again
and perhaps she will in the future
let's come back to discussing the world
building in veronica roth's carve the
mark universe a little bit more and this
is going to
very quickly
bleed over into the philosophical themes
that we want to discuss and the
as she's mentioned the connections to
characters
and story you know there's no
world in this case without it being an
inhabited
universe in which the story is taking
place and specifically
centering around some main characters as
is typically the case we're so fortunate
in that the main you know narrators and
characters in this are so well placed
within the society for us to see
everything that's going on but that's
not
any criticism that's how a story
generally has to be told if it's going
to be this kind of story
so
um
the the majority of the
story that's in carve the mark is taking
place on this this one planet with a few
you know moving elsewhere
here and there
and you know this is the contested
planet we could say where two peoples
live and they actually have different
names for the planet itself so there are
the um thuffa sits which are you know in
in the north and they have three
main cities hessa where the story
actually begins uh osak far in the north
and then the richer city shisa and then
there's the the shotet a
people who were
originally nomadic traveling throughout
the galaxy have settled on the world
thuva
and
are
in essence attempting to
colonize it and these two groups are
very different from each other not just
in
you know superficial appearance but in
language for example different languages
are spoken the shotet language is
supposed to be the only ones spoken
in the shotet areas
and they're different in their their
lifestyle the shotet are
militaristic aggressive uh honor driven
the
thuva sits are more you could say
sedate and oriented towards you know
existing within their environment and
harvesting the different flowers that
they're they're uh exporting and then
things along those lines and there's
this this vast divide between them which
is going to get crossed because the
shotet are carrying out
raids on the thuva sit and you know
one of the open questions is how are
these people going to
exist in relation to each other and in
relation to the larger
galaxy or solar system in which the
assembly is you know recognizing the
through visit as sort of the the de
facto
holders or rulers of that world and the
show ted are agitating to try to get
a place for themselves we're going to
talk a lot more about them
in a bit
one of the interesting features of this
narrative universe
is that there are
oracles and you know one of the themes
that veronica roth in that email that i
mentioned earlier had said that was in
her mind very important to the carve the
mark
stories is the the issue of
religion versus secular government and
how those
figure in with each other and the
oracles are a significant part of that
because
there's a push in the larger
solar system some worlds are much more
secular and they want to see the oracles
reigned in
you know they view them as kind of a
either superstition or if they're
actually onto something their their
oracles should be made public so
everybody could know
uh and and that's you know kind of an
interesting side point but i think that
another thing that we can say is the
question is well what do we make of
these oracles themselves that play a
very significant role so from the very
beginning in
carve the mark we have a family
that actually has
two oracles in it the
oracle sifa who is the mother to
the uh
keroseth children who are akos is one of
the main characters so as aja later on
and
asia himself uh the second child is in
fact an oracle as well and there's a
third oracle and then there's oracles
you know throughout the other places and
the oracles
you know do things like
provide guidance and leadership in some
respects but they also
talk about the fates which we'll we'll
look at as
a philosophical theme but just
realize that this is very important for
the structure
of the narrative universe and the story
going further
now what else do we need to know about
the the background
the
shotet who we're going to talk about at
greater length in a bit
they are ruled by a ruling family lasmet
is the you know sort of father figure to
these these two ryzek and and kira uh
and he's presumably dead or gone or
something like that
and this is a really recent dynasty um
ryzek is only the third in line because
it was losmet's mother
who actually took power in a coup
when the uh
noahvec family became
fated by the oracles when there started
to be predictions
about them and so they took that as
a sign that they were meant to rule and
they have been
and the shotet have been becoming
more aggressive but also in some
respects uh more oppressed and
impoverished as we're going to see
throughout those those generations which
are the the recent history of
this
this entire story
so on uh thuva on that world
there are three
fated
families three families that are on the
oracle's horizon that they give
predictions about and so they include
the
three children of the keraseth family
the two children of the novik family
and the
two children of the benefit family one
of whom doesn't think sh that she has
a
fate
uh but it actually turns out that that
she does
so you know what have we got going on
here
we've already mentioned that we are
going to go to other planets as well
but
you know this is this is really what's
driving things there are you could say
greater machinations taking place within
the assembly between these different
worlds but what's happening between
these two cultures or civilizations or
societies
on
this single world is what is driving the
majority of the story
as veronica roth herself observed one of
the key and deep complex philosophical
themes that is running throughout these
novels really inextricable from it is
what we can call that of
fate versus free will and this gets
framed in a number of different ways
outside of the car of the mark universe
as like
causal determinism versus
you know complete freedom of the will or
something in between where they can
interconnect in some way very often we
call this libertarianism
not to be associated with the political
doctrine of course but a metaphysical
doctrine about uh our human freedom and
then somewhere in the in between we have
what's often called
compatibilism and this is something that
has been discussed for a very very long
time in uh western philosophy it really
gets going
in the hellenistic era and with all
sorts of interesting discussions and
contributions made by really all of the
schools of philosophy
as well as thinking in terms of whether
astrology works or not and if it does
how it works and religious doctrines and
it just gets more complicated as things
go on but the the key here you could say
that there's
several different problems built into
the question of you know fate versus
free will one of them is this sort of
large-scale
matter you know whether or not our
individual actions are free or not is
there kind of an overriding
fate for a person's life or even for you
know an entire
nation
that says the outcome has to be this way
you know how you get there whatever
paths you take you're sooner or later
going to wind up over
here so that's one
way of understanding it another way is
you know thinking about causality itself
that the things from
earlier determine what is going to be in
the present and in
the future so less a you know where
you're going sort of thing and where
you're
where you've you've been impelled to go
from the past right and so here we could
talk about like the product of
environment and culture
and certain life experiences like
traumas or even genetics and stuff like
that and then we can also talk about
like when it comes to individual actions
are they
free or are they just you know responses
to things that then afterwards we
rationalize and say i freely chose this
rather than
that you know and these are
these are not all of the questions
connected with
fate and free will or determinism and
free will but they do cover a lot of the
the ground and all three of them play
important roles in here there are like
cusp moments where somebody has to make
a decision and the decision might not
necessarily be
what to do it might also be what to say
or what to think or how to think about
things right we see a lot of
transformation
of characters taking place
so the the big elephant in the room of
course
is the predictions by the oracles and
this adds something else into it that
you know we do have
plenty of corresponding examples of in
our own uh you know long history you
know of people being told this is this
is you know what is going to be the case
for you
in this universe
most people don't actually have faiths
just just a few people do
and it's presented as if
you can't get away from your fate
there's just no way whatsoever
to
regain the system the system has already
been gamed you could say
and to modify
the outcome that has been
determined or or decided
and um
let's let's talk about about these fates
a bit because this is one way in which
things do get determined and this is
going to be driving the story in so many
incredibly complex ways so we've got
three fated families
on thuva right we have the
uh
keroseth family three kids who have
faith other people in the family had
fates as well
and so here's how it runs right
they don't say
the child so and so by name has this
faith they just say the first child of
the family xyz and that's what they do
so the first child of the family
keroseth
will succumb to the blade
not a great fate but at least you know
like watch out for edged instruments or
things like that
the second child of keraseth will see
the future of the galaxy
okay well we'll talk about that in a
moment the third child of the family
keroseth will die
in service to the family no avec now
notice there that
the fates are getting entangled right
it's not just that you know to take the
title the fates divide it's also the
fates get knotted up into each other so
the
um third child of the family keroseth
will die in service to the family no
avec
these are two of the you know major
families on different sides of the
planet and so
dying in service to a shotet family is
not a good thing for
the thuvasat people
turning now to the no no avec the first
child of the family noavik will fall to
the family benefit notice another
reference to a different family right
the second child of no no avec will
cross the
divide
go from being on the
shotet side to the through visit side
and then finally we have the benecit
family
the first child of the family benefit
will raise her double to power now this
is
uh oriave or or aura and she doesn't
know that she actually has a fate
because it's been concealed from her her
sister
esai the second child of benecit will
rule
over
thuva
so
you notice you put all these together
and you've got this complex pattern of
interaction that looks good for some
people bad for others good for some
families not so good for others you know
so for example if
isa is actually able to live out her
fate she's going to rule over thuva
which means ruling over not just the
thubasit but the
shotet as well so that's not good news
for the
dynasty noavik ruling over the shotet
people right and they've already got
some bad news the first child of novik
is going to fall to the family benefit
maybe that's why benefit will rule over
thuba you know
until things actually play out we don't
really know
how to interpret these and i'm going to
give you some spoilers here because
you know i'm assuming that people have
actually read these i'll try to keep
them
fairly light spoilers and i'm going to
keep the biggest one
out of discussion the total like flip
everything on its side
i will say this so
succumbing to the blade does not mean
necessarily
dying from the blade right so these
references to falling
death you know
um all these sorts of things or or you
know dying in service
they don't necessarily
mean exactly what we think that they do
or what
you know the characters interpret them
as which which drives their actions in
in many ways
so succumbing to the blade in the case
of [ __ ] means she she will in fact be
stabbed pretty bad she won't die as a
result so you have to interpret these um
you know kind of carefully
and
let's talk about one other thing with
respect to the
oracle that that helps to drive the
storyline
whenever you have oracles
there's always people that are unhappy
with their fates and they want to figure
out can we
rework this in some way
and that is what ryzek the ruler of the
shotet people uh the son of losmet uh
who is a very you know tough ruler ryzek
is somebody who's been sort of you could
say you know abused and bullied into
becoming a leader and he's also driven
by his his own fear
and he's quite cruel
and he uses uh many other people as
instruments of his cruelty
but the thing that that sets off the
entire story
in carve the mark is this raid
where um
the shotet soldiers are coming in
and
they're going to the keraseth home where
they end up killing the the father
and um taking away the two younger
brothers aja and and uh
akkos and why are they doing that
akkos is sort of an add-on
but the real thing is is asia aja is
himself an oracle
and so
ryzek thinks that if he can like you
know take the oracles and somehow
experiment upon them or you know some do
something
maybe
he can avoid his fate and maybe he can
not only avoid
himself you know being
somebody who who's you know viewed as a
failure from the shotet perspective he's
not as strong as he needs to be doesn't
conquer
maybe he can also
avoid uh the fall of his family as well
right so there's a lot of things riding
on this
it's going to turn out that he is going
to subvert the oracle
but in a strange way that has to do with
his current gift which we'll talk about
shortly before we get to current gifts
though
um we should talk about other ways in
which people seem to be kind of
faded right so we can talk not just
about having actual fates but we could
talk about all the other kinds of
determinism that we you know ascribe to
people
in our own time and which people have
throughout history one of these would be
we could call it geographical or ethnic
determinism something very common in
ancient society you know the greeks have
this kind of goldilocks theory that you
find several uh authors talking about
which is really kind of ridiculous when
you when you get to it but it includes
these vast ethnic stereotypes like
people in the north they're very you
know passionate and excitable
uh but they're not very smart you know
but at least they're
driven by thumbos people in the south
and and to the east like the babylonians
and the egyptians very smart but you
know they lack drive the greeks are in
the place where it's just right you know
and then you can break it down into
different kinds of greeks like well you
know those who live up in in the north
are kind of stupid and brutish and you
know
we could go on and on and on right but
people do this sort of thing well i grew
up in this place so i have to
have this kind of character i got to
talk this way i got to walk this way
and you know what share of that is in
fact like picking up your culture and
your habits and what part of it is
you choosing it at some point there's
probably a very complex interaction
right
so that plays a big role
and you know particularly for the shotet
people there is a lot of social pressure
and sometimes overt political pressure
going on
within their own culture and society so
you know can you say that
ryzek and kira are products to some
degree not just of their their
shotet society but also of the family
that they belong to definitely i mean
you know
trauma has its own sort of you know
causal
uh
dynamic we could say or interactions
with things both of them have been
traumatized considerably by their their
father in particular uh and then you
know ryzek and kyra you know kind of
traumatize each other in different ways
it goes more the one way
than the other
growing up in a loving home
uh can play a very important role too
you know the experiences
that one goes through and then we can
talk about like the larger
history that people are involved in
particularly once things start heating
up and turning into an actual war
between the uh through visit and shotet
people in the fates divide in particular
this winds up being
extremely significant you know which
side are you going to be on um they've
done an action don't we have to counter
respond right we can talk about those as
being involving freedom but also
responding to the situation that you're
in sometimes you feel as if you're not
actually
free to
for example not retaliate right if
you're in charge of an entire people
as ese is is the chancellor you know
as a young woman too
so there's there's a lot of stuff going
on and then the last thing we should
talk about which is a very interesting
idea
and also
does tie in with this this big theme of
you know
fate versus freedom
current gifts right
and you know roth incidentally took a
lot of heat
from people
who
you know viewed particularly the
character kira um as who suffers from
terrible pain right and can pass that
pain on to other people
they
they viewed it as like her trivializing
chronic pain by calling it a gift but
you know
the characters and roth are super clear
that every current gift can also be a
current bane or a you know whatever the
opposite of gift is you know
a current harm and
there's there's actually you know quite
an interesting story
in the end and other beginnings right in
in this uh
two for one called the armored ones
we focus in
first on
this character who played an important
role in the overall story but now gets
her own little space and that is teca
who has had her eye plucked out
she's one of the renegades from the
shotet and losmet has actually taken her
eye
and um
she uh
actually it was risik rather when isaac
novak found out that my mother was gone
he had my brother killed in my right eye
cut out it was bobbing in a jar in the
weapons hall at novak no avec manor
and she
is on a mission to kill
um
kira novayak sister of the sovereign of
shotet better known as rhizex scourge
and she you know gets her way into
uh the very room where where she is and
she you know she finds out that this
monster
is actually a woman who has a
current gift that is
very
difficult for her to
manage
so let's talk about current gifts well
what's the current to begin with and
this is another interesting like
comparison thing some people have been
like oh
you know this is just star wars is the
force uh in a different form no no it's
not that at all as a matter of fact the
current is visible
and you can actually fly around in in
the solar system and go through it and
all that and the current runs through
everything it's like the force in that
respect right but it's not tied to
whatever little bacteria they they had
in that that story
instead it's it's a physical
manifestation that you can actually
see and experience and it's stronger in
some places they mention for example
current gifts going haywire when you're
actually
on the planet of uh ogra
right here we go this is this is um
teca again current gifts go haywire on
ogra we're not sure how yours will do so
you sit in the back right
and
why well because some current gifts are
stronger and some current gifts are
weaker and a lot of the characters that
we're encountering in this story have
some pretty serious
current gifts for example
no no avec
one of his current gifts
his current gift allows him to actually
like you know
make people do what it is that he wants
to do he can like compel their own wills
um and you know like make them cut out
their own eye or do other things
um
[Music]
kira her current gift is a pretty
terrible for her
she feels
pain throughout her body it's actually
you can see shadows across her
limbs her skin you know up into her neck
and the pain gets gets quite serious she
can transfer her pain to other people as
she in fact does to her mother killing
her mother in the process and you know
quite a few other people in the story as
well
she you know she needs to take some
pretty serious painkillers in order just
to manage and she's used by her brother
ryzek as sort of an enforcer she can
torture anybody by just imposing
horrible pain on them and we see you
know
that happening early on in the story
ryzek his gift is to swap memories with
people he can go into your brain
take out a memory and substitute one of
his own memories so he does that with
kira he does that with other people
can be very useful for intelligence
gathering
he will actually use that with asia
allow them to become essentially a
shared being a shared consciousness
living in two bodies until his body
is killed and asia becomes this
composite
being a composite human
who um
you can't really say if he's one or the
other he's he's really both
um some of the other really interesting
current gifts
akkos has a kind of null gift right
he
can nullify other people's current gifts
and he's not affected by the current
which is why
as a captive
he can
earn his armor by going up to one of the
armored ones these these gigantic
armored creatures that roam the planes
that
don't like the current they they don't
like the current that they perceive in
human beings that's why they attack them
it doesn't uh uh
feel that with him as in fact his touch
is soothing to the creature the creature
who he will then poison in order to get
its armor after taking it into camp and
threatening to let it loose on all of
the people in the military camp
and you know there's other interesting
gifts as well um
[ __ ] has this this power that allows
her to like you know
modify people's emotions
by changing the mood you could say of
the room you know making people
happier making them uh more at ease and
and things like that
um you know we can talk about uh uh
the soldier who is there at the very
beginning and run really in a lot of
these stories
uh who doesn't feel any pain that is his
gift right
and um vas
that that's it um and now all of these
sound
except for the pain one right sound
pretty great
but they all also come with
strings attached you could say so [ __ ]
for example has a very hard time
saying things that will make people
upset or uncomfortable and that's so her
gift is also a restriction
akkos um doesn't have a gift in in a
certain respect right his gift is to
take away gifts
um
isaac as we mentioned he's got to swap
memories one for the other so he loses a
little bit of himself by taking somebody
else's
things
vac who doesn't feel pain
also is kind of a slob about his body as
a result he doesn't realize he has to
like check himself like a leper does to
see whether he like busted up any of his
fingers
as he was going around his day and he
you know has a
some restrictions because of that as
well so these these current gifts
um that everybody has
they're not fates but they do kind of
channel you going in this direction or
going in this direction
in what you would do with your life so
this this issue of you know fate versus
freedom very important in these stories
i would say
the very title of the first volume in
this duology carve the mark
references a shotet ritual which has to
do with carving and tattooing
marks of those whose whose lives you've
taken
and this is sort of emblematic of a
honor-based warrior culture that we
encounter at the very beginning of carve
the mark as the ones who are you could
say in in a
higher position they're better situated
they're the ones who do the raiding
they're the ones who have a powerful
leader and a dynasty running the show
and they have prospects for taking over
the planet and you know possibly
destroying or enslaving the other main
culture
on there the one that the planet is
actually named after and so we encounter
them
as a very
powerful force but as we get further and
further into the stories we find that
they're not as unified as they appear to
be
things aren't as good within their
society people are quite unhappy
and a lot of people are just driven by
fear and greed and
aversions and you know the
need for revenge and the need to have a
little bit of status it actually starts
to look less and less like a you know a
viable warrior society and looks like
the hot mess that warrior societies
typically
end up turning into
a theme by the way that goes all the way
back to plato's republic doesn't it
um and
you know there's there's a number of
other important you could say rituals
and
differentiators for the shotet people
one of them that we see um discussed
both in the books and also in the story
the armored ones
has to do with getting armor and that is
something that akkos himself does
by using his current gift to
to essentially um
you know
disable an armored one these this is the
subtitle of armored ones is also two
stories of shotet metal right
m-e-t-t-l-e meaning you know the ability
to fight the ability to endure
and so akkos um you know is a good
example of that and he'll actually carve
the mark of the armored one into his own
flesh
so you know another one of the really
important rituals
has to do with this ship which they
actually use the shotet they get on
their ship which was you know the ship
through which they wandered the galaxy
or the solar system
for uh years and years and years and
they go off to other planets to
um
you know to
scavenge officially now
in in recent years they've also begun
you know raping and pillaging and doing
all sorts of things that are not
supposed to be in there and you know you
could look at the shotet as kind of a
people of
overreaction in some degree
so
originally before they settled on thu
visit they were
wandering from place to place throughout
the galaxy well the solar system which
they call the galaxy
driven by the currents and um exploited
and enslaved and abused by
people of other planets and so they
decided well we need to become tough we
need to become strong then we will be
respected we will not be victimized
anymore and they go the other way you
could say by overreaction and then you
know wind up wanting to take over this
planet that they have settled on
and come to you know view others as
sort of their natural prey you almost
might say and at the same time they're
trying to get themselves a a position
within the assembly to be recognized
as a people so this is a kind of
backdrop we should also mention that a
lot of what's going on has to do with
who's in charge
and you know as we come into it as i
mentioned before we
the setting is of a dynasty controlling
um the the shotet the novaya novx
and
they are
actually impoverishing their their
people
uh medicines good foods things like that
are being hoarded by the ruling
family and then distributed to their
followers while the rest of the shotet
go without and
you know this leads to
a resistance movement the renegades who
wind up um you know living in a variety
of places including within you know the
the actual um
you know
organization you could say of power
there on shotet but also on ogra and in
the brim and in many other places and
the second story of of shotet metal well
actually the first story of shotet metal
rather in armored ones
is um
that of kira
and kira is
from one of these families that has um
you know been victimized by the nuavx
and she's very angry and we encounter
her as well
in these stories
and she plays a pretty significant role
as do some of her other
fellow
renegades as well
and so
you know this this people and i
mentioned you know veronica roth in that
email she had said
violence versus mercy this is what she
takes as being one of the key themes and
i think you see that over and over and
over again
how do you
deal with somebody who
you have a history with who
views you as an enemy and has behaved in
antagonistic persecutory exploitative
ways towards you
who you think is looking down on you how
do you deal with this especially once
things start flying you know
there's some very difficult decisions
that wind up getting
taken about how much violence we can
escalate to this is a problem for the
chancellor of the
uh thu sit right
she has to decide whether to target the
the
ship that the the
shotet use and the ship is not just a
utilitarian construction right
it is their means to travel the galaxy
to once again reconnect with the nature
of their people she destroys it now what
what sort of response is required after
that you know what sort of cruelties can
be imposed upon people and then perhaps
later forgiven what kind of antagonisms
can be overcome
and i want to end this by bringing up a
theme that i'm not going to try to
explore in full detail in part because i
want to keep this relatively
on time so that we can have a good you
know follow-up discussion session after
this and i don't want to give away too
much but
here's one thing you can say
among all the other things that these
books are right
and you can call them coming-of-age
stories if you want uh you know but also
stories of vast
you know imaginative sophistication and
depth dealing with
you know where
people human beings are going in this uh
this alternate universe
among all the other things that this is
it is a love story
and
it's you know it's it's a love story
between these two
characters whose fates divide them but
fates also entwine them uh kiera novayak
and um
uh
akos keraseth right
they spend a lot of time together the
the first you know book is all told
in or from their perspective much of the
second book is as well their two
families are intimately connected
and they're both um
you know traumatized
characters who have to figure out what
they're going to do they're both very
strong-willed um they're both at a loss
a lot of the time
they come to
you know their their enemies at first
akkos is there to help take the pain
away
from kira and he can do that by just
touching her he can also do so by
preparing pain killer medications which
is something else that he does as well
and she starts teaching him how to fight
he takes to it quite well as a matter of
fact he seems to to learn or know their
language uh quite easily
and they get closer and closer and
there's you know times where they're
tested
and eventually they fall in love
and they're really the only people for
each other you realize as you're you're
reading this and i one of the things i
really like
about um this storytelling on roth's
part is
when you're reading novels about young
people kind of figuring out who they are
and they're they're going to be the
heroes of the story and they fall in
love it can often be quite
sappy
and you know formulaic and
i feel like this story
isn't like that um there's a lot of
stock tricks that people use that roth
doesn't resort to
or when she does something
like that it's going to be in
done in a very interesting
manner
[Music]
you know there's this this uh
scene in the fates divide
where
um they're trying to you know figure out
how to do things and cura says
here we go this is really quite quite
good
she wants him to choose
her
over
everybody else
to to make it you know make her somebody
that would be
chosen rather than simply
faded
and she says it's not saying yes if you
don't feel like you have a choice
and a little bit later
um she says
uh here's her recounting all i wanted
was for him to lie and for me to believe
it but i didn't have to be an oracle to
see that all the possible futures that
existed there wasn't a single one where
that outcome was possible i would never
believe a lie and akos would never tell
me one
i am in love with you i said but for
once in my life i want someone to choose
me
and you don't you can't i felt the mood
change as we stepped back akos looking
suddenly bereft like he had his arms
full and someone had come along and
taken ever taken away everything he was
carrying i felt the same way
empty-handed i can't change the way
things are he said you can't blame me
for that i know he was right and that
was why there was no point in arguing
anymore so it's people who are becoming
aware of their desires their needs their
their demands in relation to each other
and within this entire
matrix of fate and they will
indeed die for each other in fact at one
point there is some death taking place
like that and there's going to be lots
and lots of great revelations one other
thing i'll say about this too is that
these are characters who become sexually
involved and the writing
is um is is
it's
not
pornographic the way a lot of
contemporary novels do and it's not
simply euphemistic there's kind of a
nice balance there
of being able to describe what is going
on what these characters are feeling
what they're and experiencing and how
they're relating to each other so i
think that's you know a very
significant uh part of this story and it
shows you how complex these are that we
can have a
great love story
being told and it's
it's not becoming the absolute center as
a matter of fact it's one of the
main themes coming together and it does
tie in with this question
of violence versus mercy but changes it
less about the enemy relation and makes
it much more about say
trust and the development of intimacy so
that's a fitting place i think to end
this
short discussion of some of the
philosophical themes
in these two great novels by veronica
roth and the two short stories also
included in the end and other beginnings
i kind of hope that she's going to add
to this
you know there's still plenty of
time ahead to expand this universe maybe
in decades to come we'll see further
installations but what we've got right
now
is
quite rich and compelling
you